what's going on guys this is rob and we
need to talk about jane foster thor
specifically we need to talk about what
they're going to do with her contrary to
what you guys may believe i am not one
of those weird people out there who
hated gene foster i guess to be weird is
not the best uh not the best description
there there were people who didn't
really like jane foster for legitimate
reasons because they didn't really like
the way the stories were written which
is fair well i don't expect everybody to
love every single story that was that
was written out there when i talk about
the weirdos i'm talking about like the
ones who are like a woman
in a prominent position in comics
that's a problem because the girl in my
science class doesn't like me even
though i like her and so all girls are
bad you know like that that weirdo group
out there right like that that weirdo
crowd right as people who really i don't
like it when things change in comics
even though comics are literally a
walking talking definition of change
like i don't like it when things are
different like i'm talking about that
crowd out there right those guys those
guys out there i love jane foster thor i
loved the way the stories were written
it was just great to see somebody else
play the role of thor besides odin's son
i absolutely love that because i've been
reading comics for years and years and
years and years and it was cool to just
see something different right it was
cool to see things shifted up in the end
it was going to go back to odin's son
anybody who's read comics for any
measure of time knew that thor odinson
was going to get his hammer back and if
you didn't believe that well i would
understand if you said you were new to
comics if you told me you've been
reading comics for years and you were
pissed off about that i'd be like well
unless you're mad about the stories not
being written that well then you have no
reason to be mad because literally
odin's son is going to go back to being
thor so stop pretending the world's
ending read the comics enjoy the ride
like have a coconut smile like that kind
of thing you know so it's like just
chill but for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with that unfamiliar with the
whole jane foster thor thing in the
comics the way it played out is it was
really just the result of gore the god
butcher and all the things that it led
up to that that in the original sin
storyline which was really more of like
an informational storyline instead of it
being something like original sin where
it was just like a big event unfolding
the purpose of original sin while it did
have its own core story which was
largely pointless the purpose of it was
to basically have this moment
when the eyes of the watcher after the
watcher were killed were basically
blasted to the world and everybody
learned everybody's secrets right they
learned all these aspects of themselves
that had basically been hidden away so
like captain america for example learned
that he was a one point part of the
illuminati but because he didn't want to
destroy worlds during the incursions his
mind was wiped by steven strange at the
request of iron man and he was thrown
out of the throne out of the illuminati
team right totally made to forget
everything that had happened so that
whole bit of manipulation that right
there pissed off captain america to no
end the guy didn't then then with
captain america he lost his super
soldier serum in the nail story line he
aged up so by the time the eight months
later time skip happens during hickman's
avengers and new avengers going into
secret wars he's just this crotchety old
son of a [ __ ] who's like hunting down
the illuminati with the full might of
shield it's amazing
it's just this ridiculously amazing
story but you know that's basically the
gist of original sin but the idea here
is that thor lost his ability to lift
his hammer because of the aftermath of
gore the god butcher in the sense that
nick fury told him that gore was right
and the gods really are not worthy in
any real way and so with thor seemingly
believing that he couldn't lift his
hammer anymore this left really gave us
a situation where like someone
mysterious picked up the hammer of thor
instead and we didn't know who it was
right when that whole story arc first
picked up first picked up the the you
know a lot of people out there were
saying like it's jane foster it's the
most likely person to pick up the hammer
she's the one that's had the most
involvement in thor's life and so far as
the person who's always kind of been in
his corner their historical relationship
when he was donald blake and the romance
that took place there things like that
people were like for a variety of
reasons jane foster's the most likely
person but there are a lot of other
theories out there too like it's captain
america or some other member of the
avengers that you would never expect to
be worthy of lifting thor's hammer loki
or somebody along those lines you know
in the super villain community of course
it turned out to be jane foster and then
she became the mighty thor and so what
you had was basically her and her
storyline dealing with like the
asgardians who are like you're not thor
right you are you are you are not him
and we will not give you the worthiness
and respect that we would give to odin's
son so basically the asgardians that
were kind of kind of being the playing
the role of like the real world folks
who were just hating on jane right you
know that kind of a thing but i love the
stories absolutely adored the stories of
jane foster and to this day i still say
it's one of the best thor storylines
ever written in marvel comics i
absolutely love it having said that one
of the things to know is that during
that storyline right during the time
when you had jane foster thor odin's son
couldn't lift his own hammer and so you
only had one mjolnir running around
there and we all knew at least those of
us who read comics or who had been
reading comics for any real measure of
time we all knew that odin's son was
going to get his hammer back it's a rule
of comics right it's a rule of the way
that marvel writes things and even dc to
a degree that you have this status quo
and things may deviate away from the
status quo but it never stays that way
for an exceedingly long amount of time
right sometimes it does it depends on on
just the direction that you know marvel
wants to go like they brought back bucky
barnes for example he's been back ever
since but he was dead for something like
30 years no it was longer than that he
vanished in the old school captain
america comics by jack kirby and joe
simon
marvel brought back captain america in
the 60s with avengers number four bucky
barnes didn't show up until the 2000s
during um ed rubaker's run so you're
talking about
arguably 60 to 70 years that bucky
barnes was gone and then they brought
him back right so i mean that's that's
fine but like uncle ben from spider-man
has been dead just for decades and he'll
stay dead for decades alternate reality
versions of it may come back but he'll
stay dead for decades so by and large
you know with the exception of a handful
of different things everything goes back
to the status quo when captain america's
history was altered in secret uh was a
secret empire and basically he was
changed so that he had always been a
hydra agent he literally conquered north
america with his sights set on the world
he ended up going back to being like or
at least you ended up getting good
captain america back and that was it
right like it went back to being just
the regular captain america as we know
him everything goes back to normal
there's no reason to believe that
wouldn't be the case in the marvel
cinematic universe because you never
really see an example where you have two
different versions of the same character
running around take for example like
natasha romanoff right she was black
widow and so now her sister you know
elena is basically going to become
probably the new black widow in some
form or fashion likely she'll be thrown
on the thunderbolts she'll end up
finding out that essentially she was
lied to by contessa about the whole
thing with jeremy renner's hawkeye and
all that kind of stuff and that her
sister died for a worthy cause and then
she's going to defect against the
thunderbolts and she's going to end up
joining the new avengers that's most
likely what's going to happen with her
character you look at somebody like loki
for example right like sure in the loki
tv show you had different varying
versions of loki but they were different
versions of himself from alternate
realities and their introduction in the
show did nothing more than serve the
purpose of showing the different
versions of loki that you have across
the multiverse but it's not like that
show came to an end and loki returned
back to the marvel cinematic universe
and you know his death in avengers in
game or infinity war was somehow averted
and you had loki and sylvie running
around in the universe that didn't
happen that's not something that you
would expect to see and so there's no
reason to believe that you would see
both natalie portman thor and chris
hemsworth thor and the marvel cinematic
universe together that most likely one
of them's got to go which one it's going
to be i'm not entirely sure because what
you have in this movie and and
everything that we've been told is that
jane foster's dealing with a quote
unquote dark secret that's probably the
cancer storyline that jane foster had
cancer and she was dying while she was
thor like literally when she changed
back into her human form her cancer
would just start ravaging her body when
she changed into thor it would hold her
cancer off but it didn't cure her cancer
it wasn't until later on that her cancer
was basically cured but at that point in
time like she was dying as she was thor
and so it was kind of a crazy thing like
that most likely is what's going on here
in terms of that whole situation but
even then is natalie portman going to
stay thor or is she going to die at the
end of the movie because of her cancer
or something along those lines or is she
going to die in battle kind of go out in
a blaze of glory right is that how her
character is going to unfold with chris
hemsworth there's questions there too
right he's the last uh really one of the
last of the avengers that is chris
hemsworth and mark ruffalo and jeremy
renner they're basically the last ones
and that's essentially it supposedly
we're going to have hulkling i think it
is and she-hulk so i wouldn't be
surprised if they were like hulklings
basically the new hulk esque character
or maybe it'll be she-hulk i have no
idea but whatever the case is i would
say in the next five years those three
will be gone they'll be done and out of
the picture right just written out and
killed off retired whatever but they'll
end up going the way of either captain
america or iron man right dead or
retired that's basically going to be it
so that kind of leaves the landscape
open for what are in effect their
replacements and that begs the question
are we is jane foster going to continue
on is her cancer going to be cured
somehow and she basically ends up going
you know becoming the new thor because
chris hemsworth dies at the end of thor
4. no clue and that really well there
well that is interesting insofar as
that's the thing that a lot of people
want to know the movie needs to end with
a finite explanation in that way that it
can't be some open-ended ambiguous
ending where it's like well maybe thor
will continue on it's chris hemsworth or
we don't really know and the movie just
kind of you know sits there and you've
got chris hemsworth and you've got
natalie portman standing on the top of a
mountain and it's like well what happens
next you know and like the sun's setting
and they look at each other and they're
like you know who knows where our next
adventures will take us you know like
roll credits right you can't have that
it has to be one or the other i mean i
guess maybe you could do two thor's and
it's kind of difficult to do that but
there's limitations to that right like
even in mobile comics you've technically
got two spider-man running around at the
same time it's miles and it's peter
parker so it's not to say it's
impossible it's just very very very
difficult to pull off and to make work
because by and large the casual movie
going audience wants one of the other
they don't necessarily want both i think
it'd be cool to have both but where do
you fit them right where do you put them
you know is the new avengers kind of
like the like avengers step down right
is this does she get shuffled off to
like the west coast avengers and that's
where she serves and chris hemsworth
stays on the main avengers team which is
actually not a bad idea to be honest
with you now that i think about it
that's a good idea just form the west
coast avengers and just take like the
secondaries and just shuffle them off to
the west coast adventure there you go
mcu genius idea i don't know if they're
going to do that or not but that's
that's kind of my that's kind of my big
concern here going into seeing this
movie it's not gore i love the way gore
looks i don't really care about anything
else my question is what are they going
to do with like chris hemsworth thor
jane foster thor right is he going to
die is she going to die how's that gonna
work so with that being said let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section right do you think chris
hemsworth will live or do you think
natalie portman will live right which
thor do you think will be the one they
use going forward let me know what you
guys think thank you all for watching i
will catch you all later peace
[Music]